now while the report contains a few
controversial conclusions the data is
actually a little bit more nuanced
take this chart on educational
attainment the bars here show you how
boys at school are doing with their
grades versus the average so you can see
that the worst performing a black
caribbean and white british well the
best performing are indian and
bangladeshi boys
the report says actually those kinds of
gaps are far smaller in the uk than in
the us and the bars here show you that
great gap at school between
white and black pupils it's far bigger
and you can see a bigger bar there
in the us than it is in the uk how about
when people leave schools and enter the
workplace
this chart shows you pay gaps with white
british workers so you've got white
irish
indian chinese tend on average to earn
less bangladeshi pakistani groups are
above the average you can see though
that it's skewed one way those bars are
mostly going down
rather than up but the report says a lot
of that is down to geographic and
educational factors and only adjust for
them we've done that just here
it's a slightly different picture you
can see most ethnic groups are coming in
with higher pay
than the white british average those
bars are mostly above
that middle line so all of that is
painting an encouraging picture says the
commission but there's a deeper
problem some of this data relies on
small sample sizes some of it reflects
companies structures as much as their
attitude to ethnicity and experts warn
that far from providing definitive
answers
some of the data only raises further
questions
the fact is that you know the public
education system in this country so of
course some minorities
are making progress but a lot of that is
bound to even by the government's
admission some mythological
um work ethics culture or minority
aspiration
i don't really see anything in relation
to government policies of supported
effort minorities
look at other data points in the report
and actually less new ones consider
those being confronted by the police
it's by far away black people who get
stopped and searched
the most more than any other ethnic
group finally you've got some question
marks about data points
not included in the report for instance
this child on child poverty outcomes
alongside those with indian ethnicity
you can see white british people have
the lowest percentage of child poverty
by far and away the biggest
is among some bangladeshi and pakistani
families in other words you've clearly
got some
structural ethnic inequalities in the uk
the data's not telling a single story
for encouraging news
but also reasons for concern too